Okay, welcome, Monday, after Thanksgiving, I trust that all of you had a great Thanksgiving with your families and now prepping for Christmas and Christmas with your families.
All right, reminder, please ask your questions on the member's site and address anything there or that reminder that you can all jump on the courses as well.
So here's the first question that came in.
My dad fasted blood work glucose was 75. I'm struggling to gain weight. I have sent in a cheek swab and blood work and scans as markers tripled in six weeks, wondering what changed.
I need changes. I need to make to gain weight to my diet. I've added sweet potatoes, a couple of grains and some nuts. Maybe you'll need to wait until we get your cheek swab.
Yes, and no, if a person is losing, so first of all, your blood glucose of 75, it's really where you that's like perfect if you're dealing with cancer and you're trying to shut up, at least the glucose flow of making energy.
So, so I would say you're doing well there. I wouldn't worry about the glucose levels, but your, so let's go back to that.
So, glucose level of 75 would be considered on the border of hypoglycemia. If a person wasn't trying to reduce glucose levels and trying to decrease sugar consumption and things like that, if a person is eating a ketogenic diet, I've had patients eating a ketogenic diet where their blood glucose is at their 50s.
That's probably, you know, that's kind of the benchmark for people on a ketogenic diet because they're trying to get their cells to feed off of ketones instead of glucose.
I'd say, okay, I'm not that strict on my diet. I am eating some sweet potatoes and some grains in my diet. And my biggest concern is not the glucose level at that level, but my bigger concern is the weight loss.
So, if you're losing weight on a, like several pounds a week and you can't stop it and you're getting to or below what your healthy weight should be, then that's a concern to me.
So, if it's, if you're still way above your, you know, let's say, you know, you could still lose 25 pounds and still be, you know, that wouldn't be a concern. Then I put it a little bit on the back burner.
But if you're at a weight right now, that boy, this is the lowest weight I've ever been in my life, I don't think I've had a healthy weight and I'm losing several pounds a week, that would be considered cakexia and that is a concern.
So, then you have to make fairly drastic changes to your diet if you're in a cakex extinct. Well, the question is, as well, if I start eating a lot of grains again and regular potatoes and rice and things, well, isn't that beating my cancer?
Well, you have to, it's kind of like that thing with my iron being low and taking iron couldn't iron feed my cancer. Well, you kind of have to weigh out a triage here and, and basically, you know, you can't starve yourself to death and, and, and have that be, you know, an endpoint for you, you have to balance this out.
So in my mind, if you're at that cakex extinct, so these are the questions I don't actually remember who asked this question, so I don't know where this person's weight is and we should have a conversation.
So we should talk about that. But in general, if you're like, hey, I'm still probably 25 pounds overweight, then I would stay on stayed on and then dealing with why you're checking your cheek swab to find out why you're
two markers tripled and CT scan has changed or whatever we need to look at that too.
But in general, if a person is at or below a healthy weight and they're losing two to three pounds of weight, no matter what they're eating, that is technically the definition of cakex immediately the cancer is probably gobbling up any calories that you're taking and that's not a good thing.
So you, you could be at risk of losing too much weight, getting too weak and, you know, having that be your demise, so you do have to kind of change modes as far as your diet and get some more grains in.
Hope things are progressing well for your family. I listened to Monday's questions in the zoom call last week and heard the answer on the sense of testing.
This perspective, but Tom's test did show, so remember the sense of testing is the hand cradle, electro dermal screening type testing.
Tom's so this person is talking about her husband, Tom's test did show a strong schistosoma activity in the bladder, which confirmed my hunch.
This would go along with the research I saw on the CDC website from 2018 on what they published on this condition. They suggest a certain drug that is supposedly the only drug that treats this my concern is the constant reproducing.
I think the reproducing of the cancer cells and think or the reproducing of the biotoxin and not sure, should we get a blood test for this.
Honestly, I don't you don't have to ask a regular bed and MD about this because I'm not so familiar with whether that would show up on a blood test. I honestly don't think so because if it's in the bladder itself and it's not systemic.
I think it'll show up at a blood test. You'd almost have to do a bladder scope with a sample taken in order to show that I'm pretty sure.
I think you'd have to ask your yourologist about that really the CDC says this condition could migrate to the liver and cause damage as well.
So I don't know if there's any neutrosuticals that will specifically kill that I do know that there isn't any neutrosuticals that can legally make the claim that they could kill that.
Fortunately, taking immune stimulants is the best approach, but taking the drug is necessarily a bad approach either. So I would talk to my urologist about that and ask them, you know, if there's any testing that they could do, they might say, hey, we'll just put you on a three week course of this and see I don't know you have to ask them about that.
Would the rifle know to radicate this? Well, I don't know if there's any specific I know that they're specific roles and I did put some of those programs that you're able to remember correctly.
So would it actually work to eradicate this? Well, there's no way that we could say yes to that, but I certainly would be running those programs.
How often would you run it? I would definitely run it daily test to confirm the presence. Again, go back to what I mentioned about. I think the only way that you could do is do a bladder scope and then do a screen.
But I'm not positive. Ask your role, just about that.
I don't know if there's any other objective way to measure that.
Those are the early questions we have to be in. So anybody else on the line have any other questions?
Look again.
Came in well, nope.
This is going to be the shortest info I've ever done.
Well, it does make a big difference now that we're doing two a week.
We might after Christmas actually go back to what a week.
Just because we're getting less questions.
Have I written a blog post on body pH?
You know, I've spoken about it so often on the zoom calls. I don't know if I ever wrote a post about the question.
I have to just go to a blog here and see.
I do have what I do have multiple blog posts on alkaline water that I probably address that.
Let's see that's not a video if you just do pH search in the.
In the search you come up with.
Alkaline water and cancer should should be drink alkaline water.
So I do have some blog posts addressing that, but I do know that.
I do I have mentioned talked about the pH and measuring a person's pH and there's any value in doing that.
My answer short answer is no.
Your pH of your saliva and your pH of your urine is not at all indicative.
For your pH and the cancer itself or the pH of your body systemically your body has a buffering system so that your pH doesn't vary that much.
So if it did, you would die. So that's why you have these buffering systems.
You know, calcium minerals out of your bone to offer acidic environments.
And you make sodium by carbonate in through the process of making hydrochloric acid for your stomach.
And actually the my point of the sodium by carbonate which I'll just offer your body that way too.
If a bottle of highland died by one rucks should the lid shot off the lid off and overflows is the remaining liquid still good to use.
I would say yes. And the reason why it might do that is because it's fermented.
So, so it's like kombucha.
One time I made the mistake when kombucha came out and was actually doing a lecture.
Somebody handed me a bottle of kombucha kombucha and I thought it was just a bottle of juice and I shook it.
It opens it up and it's sprained all over the place.
And that is because it's a fermented product so that the rest of it is just fine.
What do you think is happening with all the anecdotal cures with the baking soda blackstrat molasses protocol.
I think the blackstrat molasses baking soda can be actually a good protocol.
If you have stomach cancer or a stop a geocancer.
But it may be even colon cancer, but if you have breast cancer, there's just no way that is there's just no possible way that that is.
Alkalizing the breast tumor is just no possible possible physiological way that's happening so honestly how I think it's working.
I talked to people in the fold that said hey, they have breast cancer and they're doing the blackstrap molasses making soda protocol and it really helped them.
They feel like they're doing really well doing it.
I think it's probably other things that that person's doing almost no one is just doing one thing.
So, and so I don't know, I just, you know, I think there is a physiological response you're you're using the baking soda in fact your stomach it's going to affect and that's the bad thing.
It will neutralize all the HCL and your stomach and it's going to disrupt your digestion, but they're claiming that black the molasses is taking the baking soda to the cancer.
Again, you're just there's just not understanding the physiology of how your body breaks down food so.
It's the molasses is actually breaking down is digested in the intestinal tract and you're it's not absorbing as molasses it's breaking down to sugar and it's breaking down to other components in it.
And the hydrochlor or the hydrogen benefit and the peroxide benefit of the baking soda is not going to link onto that so again it's it's not it's not proper physiology.
So, you know, there's all sorts of claims out there, I think that in the in the alternative perspective, not even in just in the cancer perspective, but in the alternative world that have, like I said in the past and I think give sometimes give alternative doctors a bad name with regular medical doctors because there's no it doesn't make any sense physiologically.
And anybody who's just studying physiology one at one can can kind of point that out so I think you just have to be careful with the claims I don't think there's anything wrong with saying you know hey I did this and for some reason I don't know why it helped me but when you start making claims like oh it does this this is how it doesn't.
Then you just it does it's just like the right machine you know when you start making claims you know I did a talk on the right the other day and you know lecture and I got an email saying well this is how it works because Royal right said this and this and this and this okay I know that he said those things but that doesn't make just because he said it doesn't make it right and and that has been.
Debugged there's things that Max person writes in his book that you know because he wrote that book in 1945 or something that you know recent physiology understanding is kind of debunked that and it's like you don't just hang on happy because somebody said that so you just just kind of be careful with that kind of stuff and I am not against anybody let's say i'm not doing well let's pretend there wasn't doing well hey would I be willing to try that hey I try I try anything.
You know and I do believe that your mental state makes a big difference about it so I believe it's going to work I think there may that can help help with the whole situation so that's why I say even if you have to do chemotherapy don't be you know cursing the chemotherapy you know believe that this is going to work and this is going to take care of my cancer and I think you're you have to have put your faith correctly placed.
You don't put your faith in the cure you don't put your faith in the doctor you don't put your faith in the machine you put your faith in Jesus Christ and if he's leading you to do something you trust here in that outcome you know why did Jesus have to have what he cured somebody's blindness you know he just.
You know cured his blindness and other person he made he spat on the ground and made a clay out of the soil and put it on the guy's eyes was there anything magic about doing that was there something physiological about doing that you know please so I think you know and I don't know why he did it there's different ways that he cured a person of different things different ways some he had to go wash in the pool.
And be cleansed and some he just cleansed by touching them and some people just touched him and were healed.
So I think we have to be careful of you know formulas and trusting the formula we have to trust God and God alone and I think the reason why there's those examples in scripture the way they are so that we don't as humans because we have a tendency to do this is to trust in a person.
Trust in a procedure trust in a formula trust in a some you know the magic prescription instead of trusting in God alone and so hey if God is leading you to do the molasses and baking soda protocol don't listen to the my physiology understanding which could be skewed completely to just do it and you just have to have that relationship with him that's close enough that you can just.
You can just feel that that lead in a way to do something and then you trust him not the thing you know it's not the this the saliva underground mixed into made into mud that healed the blind man.
It's God's healing ability that healed the blind man maybe maybe Jesus spat in the ground and made it mud and put it on him just to just to spite the people that were watching it like you know that's not the secret thing so I don't know so but it gets back to just trusting him and trusting him alone at all things and if you feel like God's leading you to do something by all means I'm not going to knock it just just do what you feel like you need to be doing.
Any other questions?
Okay, well we will say goodbye to everybody and get your questions in and hopefully we'll see you on Wednesday.
Thanks for being on and we'll see you in a couple days.
Thank you.